aucun pays étranger invité cette année
pour ses 90 ans la foire du grand chalon
met à l'honneur les mondes virtuels
situe elle un peu la terre tu vas voir
tu as vu son surveillance le petit
bouton
objectif affiché faire revenir un public
jeune les organisateurs ont mis les
petits plats dans les grands
300 m² sont entièrement consacré aux
jeux vidéo
c'est vrai que découvrir la réalité
virtuelle c'est très bien mon fils en
rêvait donc il le fait mais ce sera à
titre exceptionnel dans un manège comme
le train de la mine
puis on est passé dans plein d'endroits
c'était magnifique le moment il ya des
rochers qui m'est tombé dessus
j'ai un peu peur et puis un moment on
est tombé dans l'eau j'aurai des
poissons un trésor c'était magnifique
est-ce que c'est plus rigolo que de
regarder des cuisines et des salles de
bains a largement depuis plusieurs
années la fréquentation de la foire est
en berne
pour son vice président il fallait
revoir la formule
au niveau national on s'aperçoit que les
foires sont plutôt en baisse
nous nous avons réussi jusqu'à présent à
maintenir ce nombre de visiteurs afin
que cela perdure c'est là l'intérêt
d'attirer cette jeunesse pour que les
les jeunes finissent par s'y intéresser
et viennent pour encore enrichir le
nombre de visiteurs conscient des enjeux
économiques
le président de cette association
spécialisée dans ce type d'animation
sait qu'il n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
d'impression
on a quand même
on nous attendait au tournant je pense
voilà sur le fait de
ce qu ils vont arriver à faire revenir
en masse les jeunes sur la foire à
oui c'est un peu
challenge difficile pour l'heure de
savoir si les 150 exposants présents à
la foire y trouveront leur compte
leur clientèle habituelle n'est pas
forcément attirés par ce genre
d'animation